even with all the time given up to me
now by lockdown there still isn't enough
time it takes forever and
it's a good job i'm semi retired from
being a
a part of the school of computer science
at nottingham because honestly as a
regular employee i could not justify
the hours i've spent on my latest ultra
fascinating project
i refer you my dear watson to the
strange case
of dennis rich's missing thesis we all
know who dennis is unix was invented by
ken and dennis ken thompson dennis
ritchie if you want to simplify things
ken was sort of in charge of unix the
operating system anything to do with
creating c language facilities and c
compilers because remember unix was one
of the very first operating systems to
be written in a specially invented
high-level language called c
and dennis was absolute whiz with the c
compiler and he needed both them to do
this
so uh again many of you
will know dennis because
one of the best selling computer
programming textbooks of all time is the
c programming language by dennis ritchie
and our good computer file colleague and
friend
brian kernighan there's some big gaps in
our knowledge about dennis and i should
remind you i think sadly he died in 2010
and has been must much missed in the 10
years or so since that
but recently
the computer history museum in the usa
came up with a story which just
amazed everybody people who knew him
said yeah yeah he
he went to harvard
and i think he did an applied
mathematics degree
oh so of course he's that he was dr
richie wasn't he he did a phd
well the answer is he studied for a phd
but it never properly got submitted
examination panel was appointed
they never met
and the chm story
basically says we don't
totally
feel happy about this story the cover
story is that
there was a standoff and that there was
a need to submit
a bound library copies of his thesis
dennis objected to paying having to pay
to have this done
he thought he
made enough sacrifices already
presumably in keeping himself alive
while he did his phd thesis
it's worth saying his phd was a very
theoretical one
coming out of the maths department
um
perhaps not too surprising but he
regarded his thesis as something to be
got out of the way but he was far more
interested in playing space wars and
writing real c programs that were useful
to help out ken his newfound friend you
see i know you'll all say you know
everybody don't name drop yes i have to
confess i did meet dennis ritchie once
it was in 1986
brian had been over to see me in the
early 80s i paid a return visit to bell
labs i had a very enjoyable lunch
dennis ken brian and me
in which ken regelled us with his story
about if you were a qualified pilot
you could get to fly a mig in russia if
you played your cards right they were so
short of foreign currency foreign
exchange in that time any gimmick that
brought in tons of dollars you say was
absolutely fine so yes i did meet dennis
just that once and uh it's totally
charming guy it takes one to spot one
he's a computer scientist and so was ken
they were so similar to each other but
so different you know they uh
they had this wicked way of answering
exactly what you'd asked not what you
wish you'd asked ken didn't get a phd
but he did get he did enroll for a
masters i think at berkeley and got that
so he was known about but everybody just
assumed that dennis must have got his
phd from harvard there were no hitches
turns out there were
and
bell labs were not pleased to find
that this person they'd appointed who
they knew was good they they chased
after him
as solidly as they chased after ken i
think they were they were tipped off how
good he was but to find suddenly i think
somebody from bell labs wrote harvard
and said what is going on when will uh
mr richie get his phd and got back the
frostiest reply you will ever see
effectively saying we have no plans nor
are we likely to have any plans to give
mr richie a phd thesis
he had upset somebody mightily
and neither i nor brian nor his brother
bill
still we don't know the true story maybe
we never will 1967 was a long time ago
even for me
even for me just think of that
i was only
23.
oh
it's like
back into jurassic you know
and just to put
things
absolutely clear
what would have been available to dennis
for his output medium for his thesis
really
something like a clattery
model 37 teletype will be coming
available they had a fixed character set
you couldn't sort of extend it in any
way but they were very good i mean you
could have a a teletype
plugged in they were used in stock
exchanges so they were a common currency
so you could plug a teletype into your
computer so this thesis does exist then
it did exist you see his sister lynn who
i think died two three years ago
was very fond of her brother looked
after him carefully she had a copy of
his finally submitted thesis
one of his
fellow
phd students also from harvard albert
meyer quite a name in theoretical
computer science but of course again now
he'll have retired he had one and the
other one if you like was dennis's own
working copy
which eventually got
submitted or was about to be submitted
normally at this period what you would
do was handwrite all your great thoughts
and hand it to a typist
the idea of being able to do it on a
computer and with computer assistance
was at its very
very
infancy we have a copy here of what it
was like could have been submitted it
didn't get submitted
but
dennis decided quite rightly that
a teletype terminal wasn't powerful
enough because it didn't have enough
characters
so if you're going to either hand type
it or
typeset it from a peripheral stuck into
a computer
what were your options
well your options were either an ultra
expensive very early photo type setter
font characters as photos on a film
strip
so your a to z were 26 different little
bits of film probably wrapped around a
drum that you could illuminate from
behind massively massively expensive
even bell labs hadn't invested in one of
those at the time although a few years
later they did
no if you come back from those rarified
heights you could type it by hand and if
it was an old-fashioned typewriter you
had special characters on little things
that look like nail varnish sticks that
you put into the throat of the
typewriter and you hit any key and
it was like a sort of relayed impact
that alpha character was actually typed
i or something any character would do
and it hit the back of this special
gadget and you got at the right place
the letter alpha
but going beyond that because that was a
pain
ibm came up with the idea of a golf ball
typewriter
this is the best thing that's happened
to typing since electricity
the ibm's electric typewriter they are
miraculous things
unbelievable what they did was that
instead of having 26 different dipsticks
for weird characters they would put put
them on let's say a greek character's
golf ball for special purposes you take
out your regular golf ball you plug in a
greek character's one when you look at
the way that they embedded
those metal characters onto the surface
of a sphere
in such a way that if the sphere rocked
ever so slightly another row
of characters
became as it were normal to the paper
and could be
hit in a tight right you can have little
arms with a metal kind of thing that
gets at the end and they all end up in
the neck or the throat or whatever it's
called and on a conventional typewriter
you move the sheet around with a
selectric you only move the sheet for
line feeds forward and back you didn't
move the sheet for horizontal motion
this unbelievable cradle with a golf
ball in it going seemingly at the speed
of sound was leaping all over left and
right putting in characters it is an
electromechanical marvel of the first
order and did not come cheap it cost as
much well the story at the time was
those of you on the far side of the
atlantic can translate it's better than
me it cost as much as a buick now a
buick is a not an utterly luxurious
saloon i don't think but it's not cheap
and it certainly wasn't cheap in those
days so it cost as much as a
medium-sized saloon car just for this
output device
and dennis having been taken on by bell
labs
as the bright new lad
actually conned them into letting him
have an online version of one of these
devices it's called a 2741 and a
dedicated line that had a monthly rental
at eye watering prices just so that as
well as working for bell labs in his new
job he could also
have a golf ball machine down there
where he did experiments in how to type
set his thesis properly and
brother bill will point to his website
age nine years old at the time was just
in awe of dennis sitting in their
basement in the richie family house then
it's rented the basement just
swapping golf balls and messing about
with this thing in one corner of the
basement from what i understand
but even so
how did he in the end
manage
180 pages of thesis
with changes of characters all over the
place because we're talking about uh
typesetting equations here aren't we as
much yes i probably
better turn our attention to this one i
think which is pretty horrifying i mean
when you look at it there are
the obvious alphabetic characters there
but at the moment inked in is a greek
row or is it a p symbol in dennis's own
handwriting and just the sheer density
of this stuff one on top of another
a funny thing there which is a monas
operator so
this is horrifying to contemplate is how
many golf ball changes would you need to
typeset that page because what you've
got to do is do all the easy stuff and
there isn't much easy stuff here set it
back in a sense to a home position and
put the paper back in again in other
words if it's on track to feed make sure
you get back to exactly the right style
position then go through it
waving the golf ball around on its
carriage and then deciding ah i'm needed
there let's type one character there so
you might end up having to do multi-pass
processing on just about every page
depending on complexity
now some of you may remember we did
actually you may not even recognize it
as a comparable exercise about six or
seven years ago we did a thing about the
vacation memo it was a 13-page memo of
the fights they'd had with mergan tala
and with the hardware to get everything
working but they succeeded in the end we
effectively want to do for dennis's
thesis what we did in rescuing the
vacation memo the trouble is it's not
only ten times longer is this thesis
it's also easily ten times harder to do
because
his material is so complex the stuff on
the 202 we were rescued by the fact that
fonts carried on beyond the 202 into the
great new world of adobe type 1
true type fonts open type fonts for
those of you introducing there are
standards you can
miss out all the stuff in the middle
take a flying leap into the world of
fonts and things become easier
fortunately
how do we make our flying leap here here
is a font if you care to call it that
which basically exists on a golf ball on
a time writer
not a traditional
conveyance mechanism for what a
typographer we'll call a real font
nevertheless
our good friend chuck bigelow
typographer
giant of the lucida typeface family
in advising us said i'll have a look
around and see if somebody has seen fit
to turn the selectrix
font
into what we would call a proper font
and he found for us from the bitstream
foundry
a font which i think is called piker10
and it's pretty darn close to what a
standard selectric golf ball has gone
but unfortunately nobody did
the exotic symbols
and the thing about the main running
text is that because it came off a
typewriter
it's what's called fixed pitch
maybe a lot of you don't realize this
but if you have a fixed pitch typewriter
have you ever noticed that the problem
is that the letter i looks very lonely
because there has to be a lot of space
on either side of it the fixed pitch of
these characters is 602 one thousandth
of an inch okay for ordinary alphabets
but when you get extended characters
like a greek alpha which has got a
floppy head and a floppy tail
they don't look very good fixed pitch
you have to redesign them but they look
all constrained and not their usual
florid self
there are have i have been no fixed
pitch redrawings as far as we can find
into a font of the greek cymbal ball
it's it's a minority interest so i've
had to do my best in rescuing dennis's
thesis on work is ongoing or take quite
some time here to say well we'll have to
use
a variable pitched typewriter-like font
for the exotic symbols so for example
the uh
alpha symbol in greek requires
variable pitch 890
1 000 not 602
and if you start to say come on bro stop
being lazy just take the variable
pitched font and
using your innate skills oh no
squash it down into being a fixed pitch
version of it it's hard if you don't
believe me read my semi rant back in the
vacation memo paper it took me something
like between 120 and 150 hours to create
a font called print out and the results
look rubbish unless you have artistic
innate capability which i don't it means
that my lines on the rebuild are
sometimes a bit longer than dennis's
because i'm having to use quite a few
variable pitch characters that are
inevitably they look more elegant but
they're longer than they would be in the
fixed pitch version so under my left
finger is the stuff that dennis left his
display equations swapping over quickly
here using the bit stream pika 10 font
is my attempted rebuild of the same
material i'm still working on it but can
you see
the pie symbol there
looks better there's all sorts of things
for those of you saying well how are you
producing it i've allowed myself the
anachronism of going five years later in
bell labs history
anybody who's into ancient units would
say that was yelling out for eqn and t
roth why didn't dennis use them they
hadn't been invented his thesis was in
1967 equine and t-rove weren't there
until 1972 and it's got superscript and
subsequent positions and you must
respect those because those affect the
meaning of the equations he was five
years ahead of his time and lord knows
how he did it but in following him
may we be forgiven we're giving
ourselves five years benefit
and considering ourselves that had
dennis done his thesis five years later
he would have used these tools
so we have used eqn to set these
equations feeding into the device
independent version of t roth because
stylistically and date wise they are
earlier than things like tech and latex
by a bit so this seemed to us to be the
best
reproduction compromise
scene looks very very similar so if the
robot is actually here it would
say that
i might be here
i might be here or i might be here and
we do represent like that
let's be clear in all of this work that
i shall be doing now with disks and
stacks